I'm Joy Womack a professional ballerina
today we are going to go through the
different levels of ballet
in the interest of time we're going to
be focusing on turns the Forte sequence
in Swan Lake it is seen as a step that
shows your Mastery and your control I
would pick Swan Lake as a representative
of the culmative challenges of being a
principal ballerina as a disclaimer this
is my interpretation of complexity level
one plie a plie is a building block of
our technique it basically means in
French to bend so it could be a bending
of the knee a bending of the ankle but
in this case we're going to start in our
five positions it's important for the
Plies to keep your heels on the ground
and be able to feel your pinky toes
pushing into the floor the plie is the
foundation of Bali because you can't
jump you can't turn and you can't move
without being able to bend your knees in
an outward turned out position level two
tandu the tandu starts with their feet
in first position or in fifth position
and you brush along the floor moving
through the Demi point or bending of the
toes to stretch the toes completely and
then back to the position from where you
started the level 3 alignment and any
movement that we're going to do next
you're going to always have to think
about your hips and your shoulders on
the same line we are not only thinking
of body alignment we want to be able to
dance so that our audience can see all
parts of our body and we can use the
space in a way that makes sense so we
have what we call invalid or amphas we
also have a carte and these are all the
different movements and different planes
that we work in when I'm doing my passe
I like to really think about the back of
my thigh pressing to the back of the
room and I feel like that keeps me
stable and helps me really rotate from
the inner parts of my hip lots of things
can go wrong in the passe you can fall
down towards your knee you have to keep
it up high and you can't let your foot
cross over your knee as well you have to
be able to stand on one leg instead of
two legs and be able to use your knee
and your feet joints to be able to then
go on to the more difficult steps that
come after it level 5 attitude what it
means is basically a bent leg I try to
think about lifting the knee up and
trying to turn out the foot as much as I
can to keep it in that straight line in
the world of Classical Ballet and this
is definitely arguable we have three
main schools of dance with the French
School of the attitude the foot and the
knee are almost perpendicular to each
other and in the American school it's
slightly similar but the leg is lifted
higher and then the Russian school being
the most extreme and the reason why I
have it here is because the things that
you can do with turning in an attitude
position make it more complex than some
of the levels that we've had you need
extreme balance control in order to turn
in this position of attitude level 6
Arabesque this is the graduation of
paste tandu attitude you have to be able
to turn out your legs and then you have
to be able to hold that position there
are officially four different Airbus so
you have first air second Arabesque
third Airbus and four therapists either
second airbusk or fourth their best can
be the hardest because your body is in
such extreme twisting positions and your
eyes and your arms and your part about
all has to be connected to make this
movement that it seems so simple but
it's so complex let's look at a sequence
foreign
[Music]
level 7 Dev Lupe start from your fifth
position you pull your foot up through
the Posse and then you lift your heel
forward and then you're lifting your leg
over 90 degrees you have to be so stable
on your standing hip and be able to
bring your foot forward while not
letting your hips fall forward which
we're going back to our alignment and
you can do this develop a at various
levels in speed this is when you use
your Artistry to then be able to go into
the center and tell a story level 8
groundbot Mall here is a huge throwing
in the lake the 180 degrees or your
maximum amount of strength so
flexibility is imperative here certainly
100 you need the splits and then you
also need a strong stable supporting leg
you have to be able to move and use your
body and the grand bat helps you train
for your jumps so I've placed it after
the attitude and after the pasta on
purpose because it's a very Dynamic
movement level nine on point point is a
very special skill where you have to be
able to hold all of your positions to be
able to dance to your attitude your
autonomous on a platform that's this
small so it is something that you really
have to love in order to commit to being
on point and it actually is destructive
to your body to be on point shoes so
that is one of the reasons why I put it
here level 10 spotting this is the
secret to balance and the secret to
Dynamic momentum this is a technique
where we use our eyes we Face Forward we
pick one place and we turn our eyes as
much as we can finding that spot the
same exact place that we were just
before level 11 shenay turn now we're
really getting into the technique of how
to do turns it actually means chain so
it means one thing after another we
start a shiny turn with our legs in
tondu and one of our arms out make a
half turn where we go into a second
position and then we go back into our
first position you do that in succession
and you add speed and then all of a
sudden you have a sequence of one two
three four five six seven eight level
twelve pirouette a pure white is a full
rotation that you do from a fixed
position either fifth position fourth
position or second position you want to
take the space with the middle finger
and you want to have this second arm
push and come and meet the first arm you
want to keep everything on the same
plane keeping your arms strong and then
your standing arms strong and then you
want to spot and keep it and then finish
very nicely there are so many different
ways to start a pirouette depending on
where you are in the world and what
school of dance that you're going
through so the French the Russian and
the American way they all have a
different takeoff and landing position
let's look at a sequence
[Music]
foreign foreign
expression expression entails being able
to convince and portray to the audience
the emotion that you have inside and
make that something that is physical and
understandable the reason why I put it
in this order is it can be actually
really difficult to find the right
expression for the right movement for
example Swan Lake the safe movement with
the arms can be either sad or it can be
sharp and contrasting and dynamic as
well some people argue that you can't
teach expression I believe that you can
it's something that is passed down
through a relationship between a teacher
and a student and it's an ability to
build trust between your teacher and
yourself to find something that's inside
of you and then be able to replicate
that and put that into your body and
make it seem organic level 14 glisat now
we're moving on to the jumps now we're
leaving the floor we have to go from our
fifth position use our tondu use our
Dynamic strength from the Grandma so the
glissard has to be a sharp movement and
the feet have to leave the floor at the
same time stay up in the air and then
close at the same time often the gleece
side you are turn out either the leg
that's going first or the leg that's
coming in so then it looks very turned
in or sickled or you plie and you leave
one leg and then you leave the floor
only for one second and then the second
light comes up you really want to be
able to have a moment in the air with
two legs pointed and then two legs in
fifth position the Glee side is so
important for being able to have nice
connecting steps so you have to be able
to do your Palm Bay Padre Gleason so
those are all different steps which are
going to lead to our next level
petite Allegro is super complicated and
you need a lot of coordination from your
upper body your part of bra and your
lower legs to be able to do this quick
movement and give the audience an
impression that it's super light and
super easy you have to be able to keep
your ribs in and your body not going up
and down and you have to keep everything
in one place while using your arms and
making the movements that you're doing
very quickly with your feet seem light
and fast level 16 on straight cut or
beats so now that we've talked about
petite Allegro you can then complicate
that petite Allegro by adding a beet so
an example of some of those beasts would
be an anshikan or an ancientious a few
tips that I try to think about when I do
my under Shaka or my entrance is trying
to change the leg first to really try to
get that first beat because the next
Beast will come easier if you're late to
get the first beat oftentimes you don't
arrive with the right foot in the end in
the position level 17 Cabrio now we've
talked about Beats now we've talked
about potato leg row now we've talked
about quickness a Cabrio is a larger
jump which you need your ground up Mom
for you take off you brush the leg up to
a gromber and your bottom leg has to
meet the top leg and then come down back
into fifth position it's a great example
of a jump that can be a small jump a
medium jump or a large jump level 18 is
our Tour on layer it's a full rotation
it's an actual turn in the air to on
there and then you land in fifth
position for the men that's often a
double turn in the air for the woman
it's normally a single turn even though
I've done it in Dan and Acton I've done
a double assembly and it takes extreme
coordination that you have from your
pirouette to be able to get around it's
really important to keep your alignment
in line you have to have such quick
coordination for it I would recommend
that dancers really use their spotting
technique for the tour on there if you
lose your spot it's very hard to make
the rotation level 19 padesha or soda
Shaw what I think of a ground powder
shot is a big jump in a split you really
want to try to get your knee up as high
as you can so that your back leg can get
up as high as it can you have several
different iterations of a parisha and
that means different things to different
people they call this jump the step of
the cat because you have to have a very
nice and light Landing if you've ever
seen a cat try to jump onto something
they jump and arrive there at the same
time level 20 grand Allegro this is now
all that we've done before put together
to explosive music and it is very
exciting to watch the grand Allegro
requires a ton of stamina and a ton of
musicality if you can't hear the music
you can be seen as being heavy or behind
and you have to have coordination with
your music and with your body to be able
to give the impression that it's super
light and that it's super easy for you
to do for me it's a moment in the class
that I have time to dance for myself so
often my expression shines through
whether I'm feeling funny or sad or
excited all of those emotions can be
showcased in around Allegra level 21 is
our Fuentes so you start with a pirate
and you're doing a round jump out to the
side and then you're pulling in for
pirouette to your passe you have to have
extreme stamina of your supporting leg
extreme coordination and then you have
to use spot this is performed at the
very culmination the very end of the
Parada to showcase the ballerinas Pros
develop Arenas technical Mastery it can
go wrong so fast if you don't have a
spot you're going to fly off to the side
it's a culmination of not being able to
give in to feeling tired and then also
finishing with showing the audience that
that was just very easy for you
let's look at a sequence
[Music]
I know that ballet can seem like it's
something otherworldly and unattainable
but dance and valleys actually for every
single person and I would challenge the
audience members who enjoy this video to
go out and find an adult beginner class
it doesn't matter if you don't do things
perfectly we all are on a constant
search for Perfection but Perfection
doesn't exist so just be the best self
you can be and enjoy dancing
foreign